Esta vez voy a multiplicar 78 x 65. A ver,
vamos a escribirlo, vamos a poner 70 y
8 x 65 -x 65-.
Quiero decirles que esta vez no lo voy a hacer
de una manera tradicional. Estaríamos de acuerdo
de que hay muchas formas de multiplicar. Esta
vez lo quiero hacer muy parecido como cuando
hago multiplicaciones en mi cabeza, y también
quiero mostrar todas las partes del proceso
utilizando esta figura que tiene áreas, que está
de este lado derecho, así que empecemos haciendo
la multiplicación. Empezaríamos haciendo 5
x 8, 5 x 8 es 40, pero a diferencia de otros
momentos en los que pondríamos el 0 y llegaríamos
acarreando o llevando los otros números, lo que yo
voy a hacer es escribir el 40 completo, 5 x 8 es
40. Ahora voy a multiplicar el 5 x 7, pero ojo,
hay que ser cuidadosos. Este 7 que está aquí no es
cualquier 7, está en la posición de las decenas,
así que es 70, 5 x 7 me da 35, y 5 x 70, pues
que es un 0 más, me da 350. Y ahora lo voy a
escribir aquí: 350. Ahora voy a multiplicar el
6 x 8, pero otra vez tenemos que ser cuidadosos,
este no es cualquier 6, este está en la posición
de las decenas, por lo que es 60, hay que
multiplicar 60 x 8, 6 x 8 48 y si le agrego un
0 pues es 480. Muy bien, ahora vamos con el que
sigue que es el 6 x 7, pero siguiendo la idea
este no es cualquier 6, ni este es cualquier 7,
en realidad estamos multiplicando 60 x 70, esto
es si los números tienen un 0 como en el 60 y en
el 70, voy a agregar el número de ceros que tengan
en total, o sea dos, 6 x 7 42, y dos ceros me da
4200, y lo voy a escribir aquí. Muy bien, y ahora
podemos sumar todos, como le haríamos normalmente
en la multiplicación. Entonces vamos con cuidado.
En la posición de las unidades sólo tengo ceros,
así que en las unidades se mantiene el 0. Ahora
vamos con las decenas: 4 y 5, 9 y 8, 17 y 0 17,
así que escribo el 7 y llevo 1, lo marco aquí.
Seguimos con las centenas: 1 + 3 es 4 + 4 son
8 + 2 son 10, así que escribo el 0 y llevo 1, que
lo indico aquí. Y finalmente en los millares: 1 y
4 son 5, así que el producto de 65 x 78 dio como
resultado 5070. Quiero insistir que esta forma que
hice la multiplicación simplemente fui por partes,
aquí tenemos 5 x 8 que es 40, después tenemos 5 x
70 que son los 350, 60 x 8 que son 480 y 60 x 70
que son 4200. O sea, multiplicar 65 x 78 es lo
mismo que sumar la multiplicación de cada una de
sus partes. Ahora veámoslo con mi figura que tengo
aquí a la derecha, y me gustaría ir mostrando
cada una de las partes que corresponden a las
áreas de esta figura. Entonces multiplicar 65 x 78
y a ver lo voy a ir dibujando, vamos a poner las
dimensiones en esta figura, esto es ¿qué tal si
de aquí a acá yo tengo una distancia de 60? Luego,
en esta parte tengo -voy a ser cuidadoso-
una distancia de 5, vamos a decir que esta
distancia, esta distancia que está aquí es 70,
y finalmente esta distancia que está aquí abajo,
con este color, esta distancia que está aquí
abajo es de 8, o sea que multiplicar 65 x 78
sería equivalente a tener un rectángulo que tiene
de ancho 65 y de altura 78 y yo calculara su área,
es decir, 65 x 78. Y si voy viendo cada
uno de los pasos que fui haciendo aquí,
por ejemplo, 5 x 8 que es 40, es
equivalente a pensar: mira este es 5 x
8, que esto es igual a 40, esta área vale 40;
después, si yo observara cuando multipliqué 5
x 70 sería equivalente a pensar esta área que
tengo aquí, sí mira, esta que está aquí que es
5 x 70, a ver vamos escribirlo así 70 x 5, 5 x
70 es lo mismo, y esto tiene un valor de 350.
Después 8 x 60 o 60 x 8 es exactamente el área
que está aquí, que es 60 x 8 y esto es igual a
480. Y finalmente el 60 por el 70 que nos da 4200
es el área que está aquí, que es 70 x 60 = 4200,
así que la operación que hice es el equivalente
a sumar las áreas de cada una de estas partes.
Mira aquí tenemos el 40 que es el que tenemos aquí
del 5 x 8, el 350 que le vamos a sumar el 480, y
después el 4200 que es la parte más grande. Todas
ellas en conjunto suman 5070 unidades cuadradas.